welcome to this session on developing
successful games with Google Play hope
you're all having a fantastic i/o is
that true you guys having a fun time
here I'm see whoo exactly let's get
energized I know it's ten o'clock in the
morning but let's get excited for game
stuff right did you guys enjoy all the
festivities last night
yes seeing some nodding heads do you
guys like the blankets they were handing
out because it was freezing I certainly
did I grabbed one of those so I'm Ben
Frankel I'm a product manager in the
Play Games team and in this session I'm
going to provide you an overview of what
play games is doing for game developers
and I'm joined today by my esteemed
colleague Ti who's going to go into the
nitty gritty details of how to implement
both play games and other Play services
and we also have a very special guest
with us today
Duke Kim from netmarble who's going to
talk about both a background for
netmarble what games they have as well
as what they're doing with Play games
and play overall to improve their
business but first let's see a quick
show of hands how many of you in this
room are game developers or involved in
the game industry excellent that is
virtually everybody I do see a few
familiar faces from the session I did
earlier in the week how many of you are
at that session good amount all right
well the good news for you I'm not gonna
bore you with the same material there is
fresh content here and plenty of it
but for those of you who were not there
I'll go and provide some background on
what Play game services is all about so
our mission is to provide developers the
tools and services they need to create
great games and make money while they're
doing it too and in 2013 an IO we
launched Play game services for the
first time and when we launched we had
the basics we had achievements we had
leaderboards we had a multiplayer stack
and so on and so forth and since then
we've become the fastest growing game
Network
ever fast-forward to today and each
month hundreds of millions of people
sign in to play game services and 50% of
the top 500 games are integrated but
over the years the needs of developers
have evolved substantially and we've had
to evolve along with them and so play
game services has since expanded to
offer things like video recording and
predictive analytics and tools to
support live operations and another way
we've had to evolve is we needed to
start bringing our tools to the
different products that our partners
here and in particular what we observed
after a number of conversations with
large developers and small developers
that day developers typically fell into
one of two camps they either had their
own game engine that that was that was
built in C++ or they used a game engine
oftentimes a unity or a cocos2d
so just a quick show of hands how many
you have your own game engine that
you've built in C++ specifically how
many you have something that your own
game engine not built in C++ but another
language didn't think so all right that
is not a real thing it turns out and
then how many use a game engine of some
sort okay that's the vast majority of
the audience and that makes sense and
which is why when we looked at what our
partners were doing we we realized we
absolutely had to have support for game
engines so we we actually have a unity
plug-in that is a open source project
that we maintain on github and you can
go check it out and make use of those
services immediately in addition to that
we also a couple years ago launched our
C++ SDK so that for those of you who do
not greatly enjoy crossing the J&I
bridge into java land for doing all of
your integrations you can do them
directly in C++ instead and it just so
happens that if you have a C++ SDK it's
relatively easy to integrate play game
services into game engines that built
also on C++ and cocos2d is just such a
game
and they have native support for a
number of different play game services
features to make it very easy to
integrate and we're working with
partners to deepen and simplify
integrations all the time and we're
always on the lookout for new and
exciting game engines to partner with
one recent entry in the game engine fray
is default I don't know how many are
familiar with default but default is a
lightweight game engine from our friends
at King and it's a tool that makes it
very very easy to make games it's a
simplified developer experience so
developers can focus on the fun and
engaging part of the game and a few
months ago they gave me a sneak preview
of their integration with Play game
services and I was blown away at how
simple it was I had to do a double-take
because the integration looked so easy
and and this is how it works for them so
you first have to go into the Play
Developer console and grab an ID this is
a very easy thing to do and then you go
into the default management console and
copy and paste it in there somewhere and
then once you've done that very small
bit of work you can then in a single
line of code integrate sign in with Play
game services so it's almost
instantaneous and when they showed it to
me it was something that I believe all
game engines should ultimately aspire to
be able to accomplish it should take
less than an hour to integrate and they
really bring that vision to fruition and
we're excited to see them launch their
Play game services support later this
year so there's a lot of other territory
we could cover but I'm going to focus on
three things that Play games can do to
help you engage and retain your players
so first we're going to talk about how
the Play games video recording API can
help you harness the energy and
enthusiasm of your gaming community to
deepen player engagement then we'll
cover how you can make dynamic updates
with services that play game services
provides and finally we talk about how
you can use our predictive analytics to
tune and tailor your game to different
player segments
so let's kick things off with how we can
help you deepen your engagement with
your player community so for a bit of
background late last year we made it
possible for players to record their
gameplay from the play games app and in
the next few weeks we'll be making the
video recording API available to all
developers so that players will be able
to invoke that same recording experience
directly from your games and Duke is
going to talk about how they're doing
that in some of netmarble titles later
on players will also have the option to
livestream their gameplay to YouTube as
well it's a really powerful feature and
we've seen a lot of excitement around
video recording from the very smallest
developers to the largest we have on the
platform and more than a dozen partners
including netmarble prominently have
already launched an integration because
they were participating in our early
access program like I said this will be
available to everybody in the coming
weeks and all the games that you're
seeing up here you can check out on the
Play Store today so you can get an idea
of how the integrations work one such
excellent integration is from a partner
of ours Chemex games and I was really
impressed for a number of different
reasons and I'll walk you through how
their integration works so from one of
the battle screens here you can see on
on your left there's a little recording
icon and if you click that button it
brings up a video recording overlay and
from that overlay you have all the
controls you need to mute the mic turn
on and off the forward facing camera as
well as start and stop video recording
as you would expect and then once you've
done recording your video you can then
share it on YouTube and you can see on
the screen on your right here that I've
been able to clip the video from the end
and you can also observe from the
screenshot here that I've prefilled
where the engine has prefilled the title
and description with helpful data to
speed up the process of sharing replays
and from Michael Chang the CEO of comics
games they said the Google standalone
recording SDK took less than a day to
implement and players are recording
clips every day now less than a day to
implement so it's a very quick and easy
integration you can do it in a very
short period of time and immediately get
your players engaged with the video
recording capabilities and another thing
that I very much liked about their
integration was that they made the
feature prominent in multiple places in
their game so off of the main screen you
could launch the recording so ultimately
you could share a much broader range of
experiences and they also included as I
showed before from the battle screen the
more visible the feature is the more
likely your players are to find it and
use it in addition to that they also
turn the video recording capabilities
into a selling point for hero tactics so
when you go into the game they would
promote the use of the feature and they
even featured it in their store listings
and all these different things that
they've done to provide visibility to
the video recording feature have been
very successful so 12% of their their
users have recorded videos and most of
them have recorded multiple videos and
they share these replays through all the
typical social channels as well as very
prominently YouTube it's a great way to
engage your audience deeply and have
them sell your game for you
very powerful stuff so now I want to
talk about how play games can help you
make dynamic updates to your game and
most developers that we talk to very
successful ones manage their game as a
service and critical to that is being
able to dynamically control different
aspects of their game from the servers
but it's a lot of hard work to set up
and manage these types of things and if
you're not a huge studio with dedicated
server engineers every minute you spend
on this kind of back-end server work
comes at the direct expense of working
on your game well that's no longer a
requirement you said in the coming weeks
we'll be able to use the Play games game
parameters
management tool so that you can
dynamically manage the different
parameters that drive your game and with
game parameters management you'll be
able to manage things like your virtual
good inventory your gameplay parameters
manage your different currencies and
create time and location-based overrides
now the time and location-based
overrides are really useful many
developers that offer time limited
content like a new character or a level
and so forth still have to manually turn
on and off these promotions and live
events so if your promotion let's say
ended at 11:59 59 on a Sunday we've
heard many developers actually have to
have someone come into the office and
like hit a button to turn off their
promotion there has to be a better way
to do this and in fact there is and it
is game parameters management just to be
clear so if you are running a global
business and you want promotions to be
run at locally relevant times with our
time and country based overrides you'll
be able to specify country specific
start and stop times and we
automatically manage everything for you
and like all of our other features this
will be available for free in the
developer console and we've been working
very closely with our partner concrete
software throughout the development of
game parameters management and we were
inspired to build the game predator
management service by the opportunity to
make it easier faster and cheaper for
concrete to manage their game as a
service so game parameters management in
the sorry in the words of Keith
bickelman game parameters management
will drastically cut set-up time and
issues while allowing us to create all
kinds of new promotions they couldn't
previously and they're looking forward
to having game parameters management in
all their future games but let's turn
our attention to how developers are
using the player stats API to tailor
game experiences for different player
segments so we launched the player stats
API last year and we've continued to
invest in a number of new predictions to
make the player stats API even more
powerful we launched with some basic
stats like sessions percentile spend
percentile as well as with some
predictions the probability that someone
is likely to churn as well as spend and
we have two new predictions coming out
in the next few weeks one of them is a
prediction of how much someone is likely
to spend in the next 28 days and the
other is the likelihood that someone
will become a high spender a 95th
percentile spender or above and we
couldn't be more excited to see what
creative things you'll be able to do
with these new predictions but I thought
I'd go through a couple of different
examples of what people are doing and
sort of the the enthusiasm we're seeing
from the gaming community and so a
developer game resort felt that the
player sets a pit was one of the most
exciting things that's recently happened
for game developers particularly for
small developers that don't have the
resources to do this type of work and
that's a common sentiment amongst many
of the smaller and indie developers that
we talk to the predictive analytics
power that we have is something that is
very difficult to do independently and
we give that capability for free through
a Play game services integration and
what game resort is planning to do with
the API is to use spend prediction to
show whether or not a user so I'm sorry
to determine whether or not a user will
show ads or see ads I should say and in
fact this other developers already
launched such an integration so
developer underwater apps has a really
exciting integration of the player stats
API they integrated player stats into
their game tap ventures and use the
spend prediction signal to determine if
users should see ads as I was describing
and if a user was predicted to spend
they saw no ads at all and if a user was
pretty is a not predicted to spend they
saw ads every time they open up the game
and they ran an experiment that compared
their current approach to serving ads to
the new approach
powered by spent prediction and the
results speak for themselves
so revenue from ads was 17% higher in
the cohort predicted not to spend and
not showing ads to users that were
probable to spend increased in-app
purchase transactions by 15% you can you
see the quote there but another really
exciting example that we
just recently heard about is from our
partner IRRI public who's implemented
another great use case for player stats
so Eirik has an internal customer
relationship management system they used
to track support tickets and so forth
and manage outbound communication to
players and all the tickets in their
queue are prioritized based on at least
today and before they have these new
predictions involved based on how much
people are spending so you are your big
spenders and people spend it all get
prioritized over other folks but with
the player stats they've added churn and
spend predictions to their priors a
prioritization model to help identify
users that have yet to spend that are
likely to and try to retain users that
are at risk of churn and we're excited
to see what other creative use cases
IRRI public can come up with this was
something that we think that many people
who have their own customer relationship
management tools eternally can replicate
and benefit from and with that I'll hand
things over to TI thank you that's bad
my name is Tahl and I'm develop advocate
for games partners
Google has numerous excellent products
but this time I want to specifically
focus on their products worked too well
for cheap for a mobile games I worked
with as you know there is a huge
competition in those segments of the
game market and the developers are very
cautious about when they decide the
product they use the product well - well
photon can be regarded as competitive in
the market moreover I'd like to show you
how easy to use them
here are five product really really
worked well for my partners let me go
through them one by one and what they
are and how to use the first one is
pre-registration pre-registration has
been a very common protects in PC gaming
world when you run show game then you
usually do the beta testing and
pre-registration and ranch who will
provide seamless onboarding experience
through Google Play pre-registration
it's one of the most effective user
acquisition tool and help the developer
from day one in a pair especially Japan
and Korea this is the most common
practice in mobile let me go through the
actual user experience for
pre-registration when a big title like a
class we are is raunchy we prepare
pre-registration event before and share
their message through various marketing
channel so the user can discover and
sign up when user clicks the banner will
follow drink ten yet go to the game page
in play game store play a place to a
story sign up for the credit right with
pre-registration at the day of game
launch the usual gas on notification to
install the game so they they won't miss
it we found that this type of onboarding
experience has the Russell patrols by
helping hundreds of thousands of users
to install their game from day one
many of the pre-registered usually
remain to be highly engaging and rural
to the games for for a long time
previously styling in Google Play games
was depending on the user's Google Plus
profile which is sometimes
introduced frictions if you don't have a
Google+ profile in your account then you
have to create it and also give a
content each game people
you start with the restaurant updater
we'll play games now you can sign in
without using Google+ anymore
instead we introduce new game our ID and
avatar which are not connected to any of
the personal data in Google's properties
and also can be used at identify you
among games so you don't need to give
the content to every game you install if
you create a game or ID for the first
game you sign in then all other games
you install radar will automatically use
it and won't interrupt you anymore here
is the previous sample code popular
games steinem you can notice that it
used to use plus the API and Scot now
you want you to just use games API and
scope will work fine if your game is
still using Google+ features such as
profiles was occurred then use the early
to add Google+ functionalities then
please use set require Google+ method to
notify to play games this will help you
handle the rest of the process the next
great feature in Play games services is
video recording API when already gave
you how it works on overview but I want
to focus on how easy the integration is
video recording picture itself is in
play games yeah and you can use it by
simply invoking the recording widget
from your game just to run decoding back
this world but please bear in mind that
the feature required to install the
latest version of the play games app and
devices with Android 5.0 or above so
you'd better notify this to use your
users before you would add a mute it
also the recording quality of the video
recording is depending on the
performance of the device and your game
here you can see the hotdog
video-recording looks like this is a
kind of video recorded by the stamina as
well and show you how you can invoke the
recording with that from your the game
and click to record the gameplay can you
play the video
thank you
you can see my face in the screen
recorded together
once you're done just click the stop
button and choose to upload it to
YouTube
I played our game okay it's cool
yeah you can stop the video
can you stop the video okay
okay so integration text just arranged
coding start our activity for recording
visual with an over a recording in tan
this API we will be public soon after IO
player stats API is a great tool to get
insight from the user stats if you know
a user about the segment he belong to
you can tailor the game experience to
make it better for the specific user the
API will tell you Russ of things about
the user based on the data regarding
player progression spending and the
engagement player stats API also predict
how the user will behave in the future
based on the Google's power per machine
running technologies it will tell you
the user will Chan or stand or whether
he will be a high spender or how much he
will spend within dust it 28 days let us
see how user can tailor the game
expensed with this API if the user is
rightly to spend you can turn on turn
off or as to make experience parallel or
his own right to spend then you can show
us every twenty minutes
if you Joe is about to Chung you can
suggest a chance to try a powerful item
to make him stronger if the user is a
has not come back for just ten days you
can send him a notification about how
his friends are doing he might come back
to check it if the user is right will be
a big spender you can show him a special
VIP item which is more expensive and
more powerful using player stats API is
so simple you can call rule the players
test method and get the data in the
result Cobell the prediction starts
working soon within just a couple of
days after pass the signing
the more he prays and the reves the
tracing play games the better prediction
you will get so please try to use as
many feature of play games as possible
it will help you get more accurate they
are and predictions and razz nap at the
wrists inept promotion is another
powerful tool you can use a problem
google play with the in app promotion
you can read the world your royal user
and the new newcomers think about your
gaming community event in which you can
introduce a new you a new game and share
some promo codes to the attendees with a
speci special in-app item as long as
your game is using in-app billing
buttons free the integration costs very
little let me show you how the process
works first you can go to the place
developer console and generate promo
code connected to a specific in-app item
then distribute the cost to the users
from marketing channel such as social
letter who are blogs messenger
once you you judge get the code they can
redeem it with in-game were within play
store your game client can handle just
redemption as part of in-app billing
version 3 finally the user gasps story
world and you can successfully cultivate
their loyal users this is a screen of
Play Developer console you can create a
promotion when you can define a
promotion with the start and end dates
you can link it to an in-app item and
also specify the number of calls you
generate
let me tell you how to handle this
within your game when the code is
redeemed during the usual
in-app purchase process inside the game
by choosing redeem option of the payment
UI this is almost identical to with
Newmar in-app billing buttons free
except that there is no author ID in the
in-app purchase data since there are no
actual transactions when the code is
redeemed in place to our outside game
the the thing could be a little bit
different you can redeem the code before
installing who are running the app in
that case you can handle them Sunday
when the game starts when the coder
you've redeemed in Play Store while your
game is up and running the store will
let you again know that there is an
update by sending on intent cold
purchases update so your game should
listen to this intent and handling
please note that there will be no order
ID what developer pay road when redeemed
in place to work let's quickly look at
the code snippet of the Rast case I just
mentioned you should register a
broadcast receiver for the intent when
you're actively in the region an undead
straight when it's paused in undisturbed
method of the receiver you can handle
the purchased item as usual but you will
see in I durable order ID or nor
developer payroll since it was not real
actual transaction and purchase didn't
happen within game in many cases I
recommend to create a separate in-app
item which is not visible inside game
just for promo code only it's way easier
to sort out the purchase for pie
redemption from those by actual payment
so far I extract I will explain and
Google Play products which was really
useful too
our game pattern now I want to invite
and interest you Duke from the mapper
one of our top game partner in Korea
Duke has been working closely with
Google for last couple years and he will
share the developer experience from his
point of view Duke please come on hello
my name is Chuck came and yeah I have
English name but it had it project means
I can speak English very well so I just
focusing on a script it's like I just
want to introduce myself I was a
developer for 10 years and then now I'm
a VP over marketing so I can explain the
developer site develop posts a viewpoint
and also at the same time a marketing
point to people starting I just want to
introduce the mobile because animal is
not popular in here right
and the mobile is not young companies
almost 16 years old company and we just
started a game machine is a fish game
teacher LAN game publisher and now we
are number one
mobile game publisher in Korea and our
market share in Korea is over 30% it's
amazing and though currently we make
money in Korea maybe 40 48 percent and
then left coming from outside of Korea
anivia number 8 worldwide mobile living
in last year I just want I introduce
mobile future fight we use leading code
for promoting active title and the taste
title on Selina April 2015 in the last
year and a top 10 grossing in a major
Asian country including a Taiwan
Thailand Korea and yeah that could lead
out in Japan and a top 20 grossing in
you
I've prepared a video to spend time wait
a minute
relinquish all resist
and your new Lord and Master
yes next time I I will prepare more
longer version
yeah Marvel future fight has the Google
promotion event for a week at a luncheon
time over left a year and during this
event usually fifthly world when they
entered get the game after clicking the
Google Chrome opener at the Google Play
way via top page or totally 40,000 users
participate in that event and I used
from court from these our new register
users were increased by 16% this number
our comparison during the event week and
that the previous week of the event at
that time our goal was how tree
understanding how to use Google promo
code because in Korea in Asia coupon is
very popular marketing methods to at all
prime and the date is a very important
and we want to expand that experience
outside Korea outside Asia but there is
no way to spread coupon but because of a
Google promo code I think we can find a
like method to use our knowledge of
about a coupon in Asia and I want to
introduce the next game the next game is
11 Lebanese a console quality hagan / an
RTG
peloton right Raven Lane was running in
a match over last year and the
maintained number one crossing in Google
Play Korea for more than six months even
liquid
this game has broken several Michela
codeine download and sales and a larger
lead Robin the mouse letting you in last
year during the last year last year Kate
Korea came over the ceremony lay even
ones highest honor country and also a
tough dependable price and it also is
called a word
scenario sound crappy and domestic
popularity here the gameplay clip of
Laban
okay next slide
yeah Laban has or has had a Google
promotion event for a week from 24
September to October over last a year
during the Korean Thanksgiving holidays
the event process was very similar to a
Marvel future fight in the user would
receive a reward with an intern in the
game after clicking the promo banner at
the top page of a Google Play you can
see the effect tau increasing new
registration increasing returning user
increasingly being increasing but the
most important thing is it with this
event we improved the retention rate
because every day user can get us our
different reward from a Google Play so
you just continuously Logan Logan Logan
only for week that is the most powerful
effect over Google from a court and even
when he is at the global version of
laban same pro poster colicky yeah
action RPG launched this year in a
Taiwan we number to Thailand with number
for Hong Kong is number seven we did
many thing for Western market because it
may be left aside left aside is a
original version and the right side is a
new version we change in the UI and we
develop the new features to meet the
taste of a Western but we still try to
understand the Western gamers because
are there huge difference between Asian
gamers and Western gamers Asian gamers
usually spend four or five hours a day
to play game crazy right but Western
it's just to spend maybe a half hour a
day a huge difference Toa the same
balance will that work outside Korea of
South Asia so that is headache over
nameable an a we did pre-registration
pre-registration is a little important
in Asia because every Asia gamer want to
be a number one yeah among players that
means the easiest way is start game
earlier than others so her
pre-registration is at the best way to
start game earlier so that means for the
mobile that is the best way to collect
loyal user before launching the game so
a flea registration result is a little
early important for us and I'm in Korea
in Asia we can collect phone number
without any limitation but outside Korea
that is not normal and we tried
collecting email we tried clicking some
of our Facebook ID and every time we
failed but we the Google team the new
teacher pre-registration finally we find
out the path to a two to three
registration campaign outside the Korean
yeah here the chart is really hard to
explain because my English problem
anyway we accomplished it out a over
200,000 on the first day of the
launching with the help of a free
registration and the Google featuring
and the Google featuring means very
powerful problem is it is really hard to
collecting core users but with a
pre-registration we believe we
collecting we succeeded to collect royal
usual hardcore gamer outside Korea
and we also adopt the video recording
feature we hopefully with this feature
we can make us our user community at
YouTube and we try now and we digging
the possibility over this picture but
currently it has just continental
futures just use your color coding and
the unloading and we need the more
feature to meet the IP holders needs
like Disney and the marble and water and
the we discussing about the Google
continuously and I think at the
launching time you can use this feature
more properly they're not and finally I
just want to cover a play of that API
you can predict spender and you can
predict charm if that it looks like so
and yeah an amiable member with big
company so we have our own prediction
model we have our own charm prediction
model but problem is at the launching
time we don't have enough data to how
can I say to use our own model but
player stats API looks like meaningfully
chart TV give me meaningfully chart at
the launching time so I think after one
of two month after after launching one
of two months we can use our model but
at a starting time the play of that API
is a very important to predict while you
happen and that we were thinking about
using that for promoting our song about
in-app item and also using that to
predict and the budgeting the marketing
budget yep okay thank you and I just
give